[Music]
under skies that present a constant
threat
and into a car park where they've been
expected for days
three buses from mariopol
through the last checkpoint and to a
safety of sorts
79 of the most vulnerable
they've been inside the besieged city
for eight weeks
among them mikhailo and his wife maria
in no state to talk
witnesses to an awfulness that brings an
old man to this
nearby father and son vladimir and andre
stevanov
situation is
and as president putin was declaring
that the city was now in russian control
a hint of what that looks like satellite
imagery from just outside mariopol
the 19th of march
the 26th of march
and the third of april
200 graves at a site which continues to
expand
inside the tent here in zaparica they
are fed
these are people who have lived in
bunkers for weeks they have with them
all that's left how many people do you
think are still uh civilians are still
in mariopol 50 000 people
mostly civilians 50 000. 50 000
thought he was ready to talk just tell
me how the situation is in mario paul at
the moment
and the sirens
a
what now for everyone here
and everyone still there
mark stone sky news in zaparica